so we're done talking because you're now
you're you're right you're showing me
your hypocrite how many people do you
know that actually
my father did
um
they are killing our children
forcing vaccines on our children
you guys don't care
thanks dirty
[Music]
[Music]
giving us all tickets here
right what you guys do yes
[Applause]
is this more fake news what are you
gonna spend today
because we are unwinding them
through love
through our love through the love that
comes through us let's just
[Music]
[Music]
how to end the convoy yeah you got to
end the mandates got to end the mandates
and personally i want trudeau and
whoever's pulling trudeau strings pulled
dawn out of canada i don't care what
happens to them but they got to be
banished they are not canadians they are
not worth having kids
the government needs to
quit mandating stuff the government is
overreaching too far
they've got to shut
mandates together shut down the
lockdowns
and end the uh vac's passport it's wrong
they're segregating
our society
um
you